[Musique]
je continue mon maroc autour de leurs
mots à la rencontre de ses fans au maroc
je ferai un petit peu un pays par mois
pour aller à la rencontre des fans de
super au jardin de la médina vois la
magnifique et là je vais retourner cet
après midi au soleil un peu à mon hôtel
et ce soir je vous dirai où je vais je
sais pas encore dans tous les cas c'est
un film i'm a man dans tous les cas ça
finit mal
dans tous les cas ça finit mal mal maths
ça finit mal voilà il a dit ça finit mal
voilà c'est ça son problème on à faire
un débat dans deezer spotify sur deezer
spotify va tous les fans je suis je suis
mort là deux heures de moto gt voir un
peu en fait ce que j'ai fait et je fais
un tour je vois un peu tous mes fans
elle au maroc
donc je fais un tour que je fais de
temps en temps yvette bieber tour là il
ya la douleur mon retour c'est un petit
peu si vous vous souvenez un petit peu
de stars à domicile c'est ce que je
viens faire un petit peu il s'y met au
maroc la chercher quelqu'un et personne
ne sais pas je suis là et ça va être un
kif et à une star qui arrive je me suis
bien remise du chocolat mes cheveux sont
en train de sécher parce qu'ils sont
encore parce qu'en fait vous avez le
visuel ne vous avais pas l'odeur l'odeur
du chocolat qui a fermenté dans les
tuyaux mon frère j'en avais dans les
oreilles dans le nez toit d'un bien à
monter via lattea chou rave ya là un peu
maigrichon toi tu vois j'ai du coup de
pouce ouais
il chauffe une vidéo pour les fans c'est
quoi au fond la classe l'atlas à temps
après la place quoi francesca antoniotti
se prépare alors c'est que de la télé à
mal les amis de mon petit maroc tour je
me suis arrêté chez bouchra loisirs
gardois la voilà à chavanges d'initiales
et comme c'est beau et à la piscine
yahia c'est là qu'on a fait du quad les
restaurants ya le spa c'est magnifique
voilà tout est beau et en plus de ça on
est très très bien reçus
[Musique]
à la mi juillet en direct de marrakech
vous avez pu voir sur la dernière photo
très heureux d'être à 15000 ait merci
pour tous vos potes et je voulais vous
dire que sur matin les 25000 ait sur
cette photo lundi je vous fais une
annonce officielle
[Musique]
c'est la vanille et dans tous les cas ça
fait mal
dans tous les cas ça finit mal mal mal
dans tous les cas ça finit mal dans tous
les cas ça finit mal à financer
compliqué on était d'accord ou qui
verrait les bigs est dit que c'est la
panique et dans tous les cas ça fait du
mal
[Musique]